emile est le premier producteur de thé
du loir et cher
c'est l'un des seuls en france il vient
d'effectuer sa première récolte 6 kilos
de feuilles
il a été cueilli hier et hier matin très
tôt et en fait l'idée là c'est de le
laisser entre deux haies et 24 heures
pour obtenir un flétrissent âge pour lui
2020 devait être un démarrage mais le
coronavirus a tout arrêté
en attendant il a modifié son site
marchand de thé pour intégrer huit
producteurs fermiers et proposer des
paniers bio locaux à domicile nous le
retrouvons à blois
c'est son tour de livraison il commande
va récupérer quelques bocaux de légumes
l'actos fermenté fabriqués par nina ça
tourne donc tous les producteurs se
retrouvent les jours de livraison en
échange les produits des différentes
commandes et chacun prend en charge un
petit bout de livraisons autour de son
lieu de production ou là où ils habitent
on a un bac frais pour les fromages un
bac frais pour la viande qui a cette
semaine
et au moment de la livraison chez le
client on recompose sa commande fromage
porcs élevés en plein air e volaille en
une semaine
les clients sont conquis on a la tomme
de vincent breton la faisselle est le
fromage blanc comme commander on essaye
de voir plus du local que d'aller dans
les grandes surfaces les queues aux
grandes surfaces où les gens sont donc
ça oui ça va être assez du local
donc on sait d'où ça vient c'est une
autre consommation une autre manière de
faire est
d'entre elles aussi de faire participer
des gens ben voilà qui sont proches de
chez nous qui font des choses aussi bien
voire mieux que ted plus loin et c'est
aussi si chacun consomme à son échelle
et local je pense que ça peut
fonctionner des meilleures manières
mg il profite de son passage pour
déposer la commande un des producteurs
dans une boutique qui défend les mêmes
valeurs que voilà votre aîné rieth le
confinement a été aussi l'opportunité
pour nous de lancer notre drive piétons
qu'on avait un peu dans l'est dans les
tuyaux qu'on avait envie de proposer
avec la mise en place du site marchand
finalement du coup ça s'est un peu
précipité et ça a été tout de suite très
très plébiscités par les clients
myriam la commerçante emile et les
autres producteurs espèrent à présent
que ces nouvelles façons de consommer
vont s'ancrer dans la société c'est
desplanques en tout juste un an
ok ils ont bien progressé cette année là
ils ont pris déjà deux centimètres il
croître comme c'est ayez dans le monde
d'après